alors attention moi je propose qu'on
démarre on va démarrer d'ailleurs je
pense qu'on va démarrer avec le couple
limo on va démarrer avec cannelle et qui
dit j'ai vu qu'elle est décidée à ce
tact et pmp 2000
et vous qui allez décider qui a été le
meilleur couple alors eh ben on va vous
mettre un titre assez années 2000 à
grands tubes des années 2000 et vous y
allez avoue je suis tu me suis séparé
six mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux
coelho
et
[Musique]
quant à quai
v
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors à brac mentent pas kamel et kamel
et kelly les deux cas la famille
kellogg's comme les analystes d'aurel
on va caler pourquoi quand tu fais comme
ça on dirait que tu pousses et que je
vous attends ça devenait trop dangereux
la sensuelle hardy sur la tête de la
mère de dieu c'est ta dernière dans sa
commune
[Rires]
on va passer aux deux et un couple le
couple qu'on appelle le coup challenger
siders ouanna et jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
le regard
[Musique]
je prie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
à l'est de moscou
du lundi
elle est là les mecs on a été transféré
on a été transféré en bal musette
ça change un peu là j'ai cru qu'elle
arbore un macaque un accord du roi sous
les toits
[Musique]
c'est moi jusqu'au cou on fait ça ça
change un peu non alors c'est le
deuxième coup qu'ils allaient voter
vous allez voter chez vous il en a vu
quelles innovations et kamel tient à ce
taux c'était sûr et qu'il y avait un
truc mais on peut on doit pas influencer
et et n'est pas là pour influencer il ya
des téléspectateurs qui sont là bon côté
les loups c'est vous qui allez voter et
oyonnax qui fera l'unanimité
[Rires]
on va appeler alors on a une certaine à
la 14e on a vu les ringards dans le sens
où on n'est pas ici pour eux c'est bon
quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on va augmenter au moins je
crois que vous allez faire la dcn le
gars il va danser ça rigolait on dirait
qu'on va lui donner du le de l'ajax
ammoniac et allez un peu de culture
danse et c'est une manière de faire
l'amour à collinaires manière de faire
l'amour apollinaire ou vérité guillaume
guillon à bien ce que moi j'appelle
guillaud c'est ça la différence entre
toi et moi moi moi sur mon portable
apollinaire séguinisme aller mais la fra
n 12 est alors si vous alors on se calme
non non ça fait une danse qui raconte
dans les règles de l'art
merci vous êtes vous si vous n'êtes pas
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
semour o
c'est brouillon et sa méthode ne vous y
les jeux santons ce qu'on leur laisse
une deuxième chance
alors il a je rappelle qu'ils ont fait
du salat monaco guide compagnie c'est
magique
[Applaudissements]
ressortir bien ça lui pomper fallu bien
tes amis du sol et mia les cela relève
des sphères me anna meares est à
l'épaule elle fermée c'est pas celle du
séduisant les fermes il a dans sa mire
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mia tu as été exceptionnelle mais
c'est vrai tu as eu dans ses propres
ouais milliard à rester classe soit
suivi n'a même pas fait ami es tu as su
rester son ami et en même temps il sa
guide on n'a peut-être pas le temps
aujourd'hui j'aimerais tellement
oui enfin faire une chorégraphie sans
votre générique là c'est vrai oui parce
que c'était bien ça jure c'est une
réunion formelle a répété la corée a
battu vannes à balma nous la faire
prédominer hichri s'cusez moi sachant
que convenance et l'autre il va le faire
que des courbes et des grâces voilà on
fait un combat c'est une des séquences
de l'émission que j'ai eu la chance en
direct poule aux téléspectateurs sur
s'est vite parce qu'on est en direct et
ça et voilà qui s'appelle savoir qu'il
ya des trucs sur les programmes la série
reine tu es tellement qu'est-ce que je
suis tellement like the light
passionnant c'est un réduit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à dire de voir ça en vrai musclée
en direct sans filet de voir ça et en
même temps c'est canalis tout le monde
tu es tu venant metteur en scène il ya
tout il ya de dominique et à quelle
heure
[Applaudissements]
ou par le talent par l'américaine
pour tim daly les pros mais c'est bon
chérif a augmenté la voix calme et tout
ça je te rappelle que ça va marcher
à la mi mai
m
est ce là
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non non non
[Applaudissements]
comme j'aimais
et
pour
[Applaudissements]
et les jambes ça dans le jeu suivant
danseurs de diou j'ai connu en mai la cp
chacun son passage solo
[Applaudissements]
m
il se passe des choses ce soir